all right guys bang-bang coming to you
live lunch money
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right I've got the beautiful
Polina here with me come into you 12 ish
Y ish because we don't got our [ __ ]
together a little bit before noon
afternoon right at noon or at 5:00
o'clock we're gonna do this every day
Polina finally gettin with the program
got her uniform on black only alright
let's get this off there's no nonsense
today we're gonna be super serious luck
in coffee what's going on they're so
shares of China's luck and coffee
plummet eighty percent after
investigation finds that the CEO
fabricated sales how do you fabricate
sales well first of all Carson block
shout out muddy waters research I had
the pleasure of meeting Carson he's an
animal
he basically his whole business model is
to go he's the founder of muddy waters
research and basically they do is they
go find companies that they think are
frauds they do a bunch of research they
take a short position they publish the
research and say hey we think this is a
fraud and we've got skin in the game
Russian shorting the stock the stocks
down like 70% or so since they've done
that of course dumb questions are always
excited to tears welcome here not
excited welcome whatever it's Friday
whatever we want
looking coffee went public last year yes
fat how did if they fabricated sales in
2019 how did the bankers not catch that
drinking chocolate chips this great
question obvious there's a lot of
questions about who the bankers were and
what kind of diligence they actually did
one of the things that I think happened
here is they were actually manipulating
the order data in their own app so no
matter how you check that data it looks
like there's actually orders there right
which then would say okay if their
orders then there should be the revenue
there should kind of be this chain
reaction throughout the business but
obviously if they made up the order data
then it's a complete fraud so this is a
malicious chain-like manipulation of the
data wasn't in just like negligence yes
somehow they're blaming the CEO oh the
chief operating officer I'm not sure the
chief operating officer has to do with
sales numbers so kind of sounds like
maybe it was more than just the chief
operating officer but it's definitely
malicious or misconduct and I would be
shocked if if more people don't get hurt
here crisis yeah yeah it's down 70% bang
bang that's what happens baby
if you risk your capital you can lose it
don't make bad bets
all right payroll data what's up with
the payroll data that's what she
preaches to me all the time make good
decisions by the way why she's pulling
this up you see the Oreos we got chips
we got some wine this is what our life
is now gone to show you know just let
them know I'm eating healthy go ahead
popcorn is not healthy not Nate there
are Oreos okay so US payrolls plunged
seventy seven hundred one thousand in
March I'm into sort of a job market
collapse do you know what payrolls are
what the hell's a non farm payroll well
it involves all the page of payroll that
isn't from farm industry why would we
why would we because the farm industry
is a very different type of job than the
rest yeah you learn something every day
on lunch money see what's happening here
she's getting educated so basically the
whole thing is there's a massive job
class right we got the unemployment
numbers yesterday six plus million I
think six point six million people filed
for unemployment numbers payrolls
another way to measure kind of the
monthly job gains and losses and the
reason why that's important is because a
lot of times you can actually look at
these data points and understand it
where's the economy headed it's no shock
to anybody the economy's obviously
suffering we're all sitting our asses at
home we saw what's happening with the
farm payrolls then well I don't know I
look at those numbers but the whole idea
here is if the numbers go down right
that means that less people have jobs
there's less people on payroll
obviously the economy's going good guys
not good not good not good all right
speaking of better news
from home jokes we've got some awesome
ones for you we actually spent the
morning looking at all these ridiculous
things people are doing while they're
sitting on their asses at home and the
first one oh this guy his girlfriend is
it his no his wife his wife was doing a
live TV report outside in the backyard
and he crashed it well he's a comedian
she's a live news reporter and she was
doing it in the backyard
and he on tick tock was like oh [ __ ] you
telling me my wife's in the backyard on
live TV right now and he gets his ass up
and he locks out and he literally goes
behind her he goes is this like runs out
and just completely disrupted the whole
thing yeah but it turns out people were
like oh my God he's so responsible
that's so awful of him but it's just the
joke they were trying to kind of go by
roll on tick-tock you did it during a
commercial break but I feel like that's
the whole point of the work from home
people kind of understand hey you're
there you've got your kids you've got
your significant other right and like
that stuff is now acceptable because
everyone knows that we're stuck at home
yeah like yesterday he was doing video
interview with Josh Constantine Christ
and I was coming inside and just walking
in the background like a creep you're
just trolling through the video sorry I
didn't mind so anyway you just see me
like Bigfoot in the background all right
what is the other one what else what
else it's funny because like I'm sure
you guys if you live with your
significant other have listened to their
calls and zooms and whatever and it's
really funny because when he doesn't
call he'll like he'll pace around and
then he'll use words that I genuinely
didn't know that you knew there's foam
exercising it's not a PC it's exercise
me I'm getting stefson you know you got
to move around a little bit do some
exercises that's how you stay fit and
corns I wanna move multiple times from
room to room so you know I could count
the steps it's fine I have a watch so
she'll be like so for the words it would
behoove you I was like first of all I
know but who means it has anybody used
that word in
the last 50 years you think I'm
uneducated but what happens is I have a
great articulation in command of the
American language English let's go
so the whole reason why you're bringing
this up is because the woman who tweeted
it went viral oh you see I have to carry
the show like I gotta put the show on my
back and just walk down the street with
her because she keeps forgetting
everything go ahead so this woman shared
this tweet and it went viral she said a
funny thing about quarantine is hearing
your partner in full work mode for the
first time like I'm married to a let's
circle bad guy who knew that if he said
circle that circle back is not in my
repertoire it's not in my my language
and then what would you say weird [ __ ]
on the phone are you like giggle oh oh
so then somebody else said my wife works
from home full-time but I remember the
day I realized she was the one more
question person at the end of the
meetings I was shucks thank you breaker
what would be a deal-breakers well right
now a deal-breaker would be if you
started coughing again I had to checked
guys just so we're clear yesterday she
was clearing her throat she was not
coughing we had a whole conversation
about it there won't be any more
coughing on the show because we have
that social distancing but a
deal-breaker would be like if you hit me
with like well we can explore synergies
if you use the word synergy be out I'd
be out all right private equity what's
going on the private equity world this
is your this is your domain I'm excited
it's Friday I feel like I have like
tomorrow off doing some come on let's go
let's go we don't have all day 20
minutes or less okay surprise she's got
the notes I got the [ __ ] go ahead
private equity lobbyists were involved
in the push for a five hundred billion
dollar coronavirus bailout fund so
everyone's getting bailouts literally
everyone wants a bailout the movie
industry wants to bail out the airline's
won a bailout and private equity wants a
bailout think about this the people who
have all the billions of dollars that
they're supposed to be investing they
want to bail out as well for their
portfolio companies why I don't know but
you know what I do know is that small
businesses are not getting great bail
house right now be
because nobody can get the applications
done on the site the banks aren't
processing it so private equity wants
bailouts but small businesses ain't
getting the help that they need what do
you think about wow well obviously I
don't like it why don't you like it I
just I hate they have a lot of money and
then the small business guys don't yeah
well here's the big problem I think with
this whole thing is to small businesses
I think it's like 350 billion dollars
have been earmarked for small businesses
in a couple of different programs the
biggest one is this like payroll
protections of PPP and the whole
strategy is let's put a bunch of money
into an account then we're gonna have
all these banks process tens of
thousands of loan applications and then
those banks will help the government
facilitate those loans the problem is
that now we're ready to go today's
supposed to be day one on Friday let's
take that not only are the banks not
ready here's even worse is that the
banks some of them are saying the
government didn't give us enough
guidelines therefore we're actually not
gonna process at all so we're not gonna
have be helpful here we're not going to
take these applications and so what ends
up happening is the people who get hurt
the most are the small businesses every
single day that that money is not in the
hands of a small business entrepreneur
or a business owner there are more
people being laid off and there's more
businesses that will not come back I
mean at this point how much I mean this
can last for months
what are small businesses supposed to do
even if they get those loans like can
you survive six months well that's the
whole thing is some of the loans
depending on how much it is could cover
you for mold for a longer period of time
but yes if they don't get access to the
capital of course they're gonna lose
right they just don't have enough money
on their balance sheets and especially
cuz you don't know how long it'll last
right if you're a restaurant you just
shut down
you don't know hey do I have to pay my
employees for two more weeks four more
weeks three months six months it was
just hate two weeks like you might be
able to figure out okay how do I get
over the next two weeks but where it's
unlimited you don't know the government
is giving this money to the banks and
telling them to without getting into
great detail think of it as the banks
are basically helping the government
facilitate all of the transactions right
or the applications so if you're a small
business owner I'm a bank you come to me
you put in the application I help this
the underwrite
that you are who you say you are you're
doing it the money and you say you are
hopefully you're not just gonna get the
money and then shut down brakes that's a
whole nother issue and so the banks are
in a better position to do that then
obviously the the federal girl yeah
makes sense all right moving on Central
Park New York City baby and why and why
what do we got so so they have built a
new 68 bed facility in tents in Central
Park
well so they're doing this all over New
York City they've done the Javits Center
which is a big conference center they
turned into I think a thousand bed
hospital they've now about this one in
Central Park that's literally intense
but here's the thing to me right is like
it's a war zone in these hospitals they
don't have enough PPE they're literally
being overwhelmed personal protective
equipment man you see that it's like I
know what I'm talking about
all right PPE and then win ends up
happening is they don't have the
ventilators that they need they don't
have enough actual hospital beds so what
happens if somebody comes in sick you
don't have been to put them in so with
it they need to do is they need to
expand the capacity that they have so
you can only do so much in a hospital
until the point where literally you just
got beds lined up next to each other so
you gotta go to somewhere else so Javits
Center big space indoors will you
eventually run out of places like that
so looking at hotels but then also they
set up tents and so what ends up
happening is this looks like a war zone
you literally have in your hospitals you
just have absolute chaos and you don't
have the equipment that you need and on
top of that you're literally setting up
tents what do you do in Iraq and
Afghanistan it very wartime you set up
tents like of course the where else are
you gonna build a building right you set
up a tent you create a medical facility
there there's basically they're doing in
the middle of Central Park now it's in
Central Park so it looks nicer than Iraq
or Afghanistan but it's still a medical
facility built in a tent where they're
trying to literally take care of
Americans on our own soil because of the
virus that's crazy
crazy right did you also see the
patients I hate the Patriots literally I
think the Patriots with like so much
disdain I respected them once more when
they had Tom Brady because he is
probably the greatest quarterback of all
time so I respect him but I don't like
him
they took Jonathan Kraft and Robert
Kraft the owner and his son there was
much of personal protective equipment
in China and they needed to get it back
to the US and the US was trying to
figure out how to do that and they
stepped up and they said well we have a
problem we've got a big-ass private
commercial jet and they sent the
Patriots plane to go pick up all the
equipment and bring it back
but don't come as it came back and had
the Patriots logo and everything on the
plane when it landed
there's always pictures of it I wish it
was the Giants that's fine but at least
they got the equipment back hey listen
two Super Bowls in last 12 years we'll
take it don't worry we're gonna win
another one all right last one lunch
money we got a little treat for you guys
if you've been paying attention all the
way to this point we are gonna do
something today we're gonna give $100
one zero zero dollars $100 to one person
to help them during this time in order
to do this you have to do some things
for us to enter the competition is a
competition or a contest is it a
giveaway no it's just nice Junior's
called nice lunch money and who
everybody wants some lunch money go and
get a lunch or dinner on us so here's
how this is gonna work you have to take
the URL from the YouTube go tweet it
with the hashtag lunch money and include
one thing you learned in the show this
week so in order to be entered to win
the $100 free lunch money
you have to take the URL go tweet it use
hashtag lunch money I tell us one thing
you learned this week from the show
extra points you will win favor with me
if you make fun of polina in the tweet
wait what we didn't talk about cool
moves nipple ring thing oh wait okay so
listen there's $100 for free anybody can
get it you just have to tweet the URL to
the link or is the URL to the video and
use hashtag lunch money and include one
thing you learned
you'll get entered on Monday we'll
announce who won but polina to close out
the show wants to talk up how was it
Andrew Cuomo's nipple ring I literally
cannot believe we're talking about this
right now I'm not sure if somebody can
figure this out so are you opening an
investigation for the Internet Zeus yes
oh my god okay go ahead okay so there's
this tweet that of a picture of Cuomo
wearing a t-shirt in what appears to be
a nipple ring oh this is the governor of
New York you start there
this is the governor of New York he has
a polo shirt on like a golf shirt
he has no undershirt on and around the
nation you know all I know well most
people do but all I wear is black shirts
so I don't have to deal with that si do
you see how I've efficient Li a wardrobe
but anyway so so there there is there
are questions and there are no answers
so I think this is a good way to close
Jo Jo's gonna pull the photo if you guys
can help plan to figure out this Andrew
Cuomo have a nipple ring or not she'll
be super excited in the meantime go take
the URL of the video go tweet it include
hashtag lunch money one thing you
learned from the show will pick one
person get 100 bucks they can go get
dinner or lunch on us to help make the
quarantine better other than that while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get a lunch money right
every day during the week twelve issue
is because we don't have our [ __ ]
together before noon afternoon right at
noon or at 5:00 p.m. you can come here
you can learn a little bit you can laugh
a little bit but most of all you'll get
plenty of eye rolls from her as she
deals with me any last words for the
weekend who view to some doing that I've
been playing with this over here on the
side that's fine do you have any last
words for everyone before we go have a
great weekend and be nice to your
friends we'll see you guys on Monday